on how to avoid this headache and truly
enjoy the day because i'm telling you
christian
uh me and uh mulberry just not friends
at all
all right well ted let me tell you it's
happening to many of us while we're out
for our morning run
running errands or just simply hanging
out outside with our pets the itchy and
watery eyes
are a grim reminder that allergy season
is here now the severity of the season
depends on the weather
how much rain and wind we get according
to one local doctor
is what drives things but people are
already complaining about feeling those
symptoms
according to dr rich vinuya allergy
symptoms include watery itchy eyes
stuffy notes
congestion and sneezing among others in
the midst
of the pandemic these symptoms could be
mistaken for covet very easy
his advice is to keep a close eye on
your health and don't
ignore it there are
a few ways to distinguish between the
two
usually when you have an infection a
viral infection like colgate
your typical allergy symptoms especially
during the season of allergies will be
much more pronounced
also one of the biggest factors is the
presence of fever
fever is not usually associated with
allergies unless you have a sinus
infection
although allergies are not contagious he
says there are things
you can do to help now try to avoid
morning outings because
that's when he says pollen is at its
peak also get an
allergy test to see what you could be
reacting to now dr
venuja says having allergies does not
increase your chances of getting covet
on the other hand avoiding medical
attention for your allergies
could cause more problems that could
affect your daily performance
christian casadas 8 news now